it's January 3rd 2019 so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
I'll talk about what we've got coming up
in January and what went on in December
I'll also be doing another sort of
end-of-the-year wrap up the year to come
video a little bit later this month it
might do a video premiere with that
we'll see I'll figure out exactly what
I'm doing and announce it later but
before that I always bring up three big
things for the month ahead and the
things that we've got going on are
pretty exciting this month big thing
number one I know I've promised this but
I will be bringing out some new
teachable classes some of them actually
free over the course of this month so
pay attention to my social media where
you'll see those listed as they appear
big thing number two we're moving into
year four believe it or not of the
worlds of speculative fiction series I
picked nine of the authors and I had my
fan subscribers readers viewers come up
with the other three so if you missed
the announcement about that I'll link to
the the blog post in or exes do you know
what to Kay about that maybe I'll shoot
a video about the series as well coming
up for the year and talked about it a
bit and of course there's the online
teachable class where you can see all
the videos and get the resources as well
big thing number three I'm beginning the
first preliminary work on a massive
editing project as many of you know I'm
the editor of Stoicism today and it's
about time that we brought out another
volume of Stoicism today selected essays
that is one of my big goals for the year
and it begins with this month with me
going through and laying some of the
groundwork for that so those are the
three big things let's talk now about
the month of December December was quite
a busy month for me but you might not
have suspected it by
looking at my online presence because I
didn't actually create and release all
that much content but it was because of
everything else that was going on I did
have a few events some of them online
some of them face-to-face here we had
the final worlds of speculative fiction
series talk of the year this time on
Jean wolf a living author had a great
time with that we've got the video for
that linked to below
I went on the skräuss is radio show
image for hire and we talked about doing
philosophy then we talked about HP
Lovecraft you can see the video for that
below and then of course there was the
monthly stoic fellowship and I was able
to take my son Matthew along to that he
has actually been studying a little bit
of epictetus so I thought it would be
good and he had a great time at the
fellowship then of course we had our
usual Hagel sessions and the pop ups and
the AMA asked me anything session you
can see videos for some of those linked
to below it was a very busy month in
terms of classes I taught five different
classes two of them online intensive you
know eight in seven week classes three
of them face to face I was teaching for
four different institutions so all of
that was coming to an end around the
middle two to three quarters mark of
December just before the holiday times
and it seemed like there was an
extraordinary amount of work involved as
various student issues and grading and
giving tests and students needing to
reschedule their exams at Marquette one
of my exams is actually scheduled for
the very last day the very last hour so
some of the students understandably
enough needed to reschedule that since
their parents had already made
arrangements for them to travel wherever
you know they were going some of them to
California some of them to Hawaii you
know the places that they came from so
there was a lot of student work involved
for different learning management
platforms you know I was working in
blackboard Sakai Moodle and d2l so that
was just on the course end then I had
all of my work with my clients doing
consulting philosophical counseling a
lot of tutorial work especially as the
semester comes to an end some academic
coaching and then there was my kids
arriving and and my kids didn't arrive
until after Christmas this year but then
they were here and you know I think I've
learned the lesson by now that when
they're here I probably shouldn't plan
on getting an awful lot done except
perhaps in the summer visitation so I
just kind of you know after I got the
grading stuff done Andy and I we took it
easy for about you know a week although
she was actually having to do a lot of
work on her end and then the kids
arrived and we had a great time with
them so you know a lot of activity and
you know getting to see some relatives
and friends as well I did get some work
done on writing I worked on that that
book project which focuses on how to
make end-of-life decisions well for
aging and ill pets I did some other
writing in in blogs particularly erectus
Deana wet DK and I got some content
worked up that I need to to start
working through I also did video work as
usual didn't do as much as I had
originally hoped I got three of the six
half-hour Haegele videos which is better
than the 2 and the 1 and the 0 of the
previous months but I'm still not up to
the full quota of 6 but hopefully that
is going to change and I shot some
Augustine core concept videos did videos
of course of the various events and so
all of those have been posted the
Augustine videos interestingly are
getting a lot of traction much more than
I thought they would have I guess a lot
of people have been waiting for that
content so that's what took place in the
south
and now let's talk about January this
month is going to be pretty busy but
it's going to be a lot of behind the
scenes sorts of things I do have quite a
few events lined up although not as much
as I do in in some other months of the
year we begin on the 8th at 5 p.m.
central standard time with Hegel Q&A
that's public anybody can come if you
have an interest in German idealism or
in Hegel or in philosophy in general pop
in and join the conversation
then here locally at the Brookfield
public library on the 10th at 7:00 p.m.
we will kick off year four of the worlds
of speculative fiction series this time
talking about one of the great
grandfather's of horror and speculative
fiction Edgar Allan Poe so that's going
to be if you're in the area you don't
want to miss that we're gonna have a
great conversation
hopefully we'll actually have enough
room for all the attendees because they
think that one's going to be a big draw
on the 12th at 12 p.m. Central Standard
Time online event I'll have my ask me
anything session open to anybody to ask
me whatever they want usually I planned
them for an hour and we usually go an
hour and a half and there's still
questions left over then on the 19th
about a week from then at 3 p.m.
we'll have our philosophy chat for
patreon supporters and finally finishing
up on the 31st the very last Thursday of
the month at 6 p.m. at the Shorewood
Public Library we will have our MKE that
is Milwaukee stoic fellowship meeting
we're currently working through
Epictetus discourses so if you have an
interest in stoicism you don't have to
be particularly well-versed in it it's a
place for learning just pop in and we're
happy to to have you and to discuss the
the works with you
classes are beginning
this coming week but the week after that
and I have five more classes this
semester I have to with Marquette
University - with Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design and one with Milwaukee
Area Technical College I'm very
fortunate in that all of these are
within about a miles walk of where I
live here in Milwaukee but I am going to
be one busy guy because that's more than
a full-time load you might say well why
did you take on so many classes well
because I got a lot of requests for
teaching and you know I people you know
the students really like the classes
that I offer and I do enjoy the
face-to-face teaching so I decided to
take on this much and you know we'll see
how it goes
fortunately all but one of these classes
are courses that I've taught a number of
times before and the the one outlier is
a really cool class for the Milwaukee
Institute of Art Design ethics for
artists and designers and maybe I'll
actually do a video about that once I
get the reading list put up in the
curriculum because that's that's a
really cool applied ethics class so I'm
I'm looking forward to that and hanging
out with my students and seeing where
they're coming from and getting to to
chat and building the course sites and
that's a lot of work then I of course
have my client work through reason I oh
I'm doing consulting doing academic
coaching tutorials I've got a few new
clients beginning with me and some
philosophical counseling as well so that
will keep me quite busy there's a lot of
planning going going on right now behind
the scenes for what we're going to be
doing I want to get to some of my
academic writing projects and some
popular writing as well and like I
pointed out I will be doing some editing
work not just the regular stuff or
stoicism today which is already kind of
a big commitment but to try to bring out
a new volume of selected essays from
the previous two two and a half years of
Stoicism
today I'll also be bringing out as I
pointed out earlier some new classes in
my teachable Academy
I've retitled it as study with dr.
Sadler so if you just type study with
dr. Sandler that should come up
otherwise I'll simply put the link below
for you so that's that's a lot of stuff
going on that's not even getting to the
videos which we should talk about now
all right you're watching one of them at
this moment as I mentioned I need to get
cracking on the half hour hagel videos
and want to get some more momentum going
get us up to six videos per month and
I've got to start shooting some new core
concept videos that I'm gonna be using
in my classes this semester so I just
finished shooting some videos earlier
today on Plato's allegory of the cave I
got to do some other Plato stuff on book
6 of the Republic and then I'm going to
get to the Arendt videos that I wanted
to do before on Eichmann in Jerusalem
there's Augustine videos we're switching
to doing Augustine's on free choice of
the will so I need to do some videos on
that des cartes meditations I did videos
on des cartes discourses but now I need
to do some Monday cartes meditations and
so that's really the stuff that's on the
docket for this month I probably won't
be releasing all of it this month but I
will be shooting all of it this month
and if I get really ambitious I'll also
shoot some and some and Aquinas
materials as well I'm gonna shoot some
book review videos hopefully I'm gonna
get started on that this weekend and I
do have a few other Q&A videos from
those old series that I was doing before
mostly about stoic philosophy I'll shoot
those this month and I might do a video
premiere we'll see how that works out if
I do a premiere you'll see it on my
Facebook page and I'll announce it in
other places as well I should mention
that there are other videos that my
patreon supporters get to see that not
everybody does I shoot these
slice-of-life videos
and I'll start doing those much more
frequently for my patreon supporters and
then there's also outtakes and bloopers
and things like that that they get to
see as well the last thing I should
mention podcasts I'm going to start you
know getting work done on the podcast
again the Sadler's lectures podcast it
was in the middle of podcast episodes on
epictetus discourses so i'm going to be
producing more of those I've got quite a
few lecture videos that need to be given
that treatment and then after that I'll
get on to some Aristotle material what
exactly I'm not quite sure I have to
think about what needs to get out first
I have you know over 150 Aristotle
videos so there's a lot of content to be
converted the last thing that I'll
mention is you know we are lining up
speaking opportunities and and and
engagements for the year to come if you
you're interested in having me come
speak send me an e-mail at Gregg at
reason IO and we'll talk about whether
it's it's feasible and how to make it
happen if you're interested in in
bringing me in you can either do so
yourself or suggest to a local
organization whatever it is a university
library Church let's bring this guy in
to talk and I'm game for for doing
travel it'll be a little bit of you know
trickiness if it's if it's very distant
from here given my teaching schedule but
you know we can always make it happen
so there's that check out the teachable
Academy check out the videos as I'm
releasing them and stay tuned for stuff
coming from stoicism today and from the
various blogs that I write for as well
as edit a lot of stuff lined up hope you
have a great month and hopefully I'll
see some of you at these events whether
online or face to face
you